[Music]
where will we go
i don't know i don't know
anywhere that needs at least a protector
i suppose oh
you really meant it yeah
we will need a cape at the mouth
no no i think you got that covered we're
good no
i i
i don't
love you no i mean i like you a lot i
really like you but love you know it's
uh
yeah you know
nah
of course eddie
you must fight it sure
[Music]
we should be out there snacking on bad
guys
i am a predator
i need to be free you have got to get
control of your aggression
we will get hauled off into area
51. live in my body you live by my walls
i'm sorry i don't know what came over me
please let me fix it so i can fix it
again
you are a loser
brock
i want to give you my story
people love serial killers
cletus why me
that's mine
it's yours and what's yours
it's mine
i have tasted blood before and that is
not it
all i ever wanted in this world
is carnage
i'm not a crazy man
you feel like home to me
like family
oh wow you could just say i'm happy for
you that was going to be us hey i'm
happy for you
no
god i'm so sorry i'm sorry just doing
some serious couples counseling
[Music]
you